Julius Caesar awaits the surrender of Vercingetorix, the Galic chief he has just defeated in battle.
Caesar's resounding victory wets his appetite for power.
From now on, that appetite will know no bounds.
Caesar dictates his commentary on the battle.
Just as I suspected, the Gauls were no match for my Roman legions.
I attacked them on all fronts, and they scattered like a flock of frightened chickens.
We captured the runaways at Elysia.
I wanted to proclaim that when I wage a campaign, there's no such thing as opposition.
All must bow to my allegiance.
The world knows fruits won't have the gall to prevent it.
If I have to, I'll crush every last one of them.
I want the world to know it.
You look pretty nice at your place, don't you think, huh?
Hey, you big boy, bring me that tree now.
About that is the question.
Public is really in danger this time,
but we, the distinguished members of the Senate,
will put a stop to that ambitious little General Donald Caesar.
No, give me that goose, it's mine.
I slept before you.
Always.
No, but Caesar's triumph in no time became the capital of the world.
Wheat is distributed to the people.
When you're lucky enough to be a Roman citizen, why work?
Especially when the city is sure to provide bread and games.
Caesar had two semicircular theaters built side by side.
At his signal, the two enormous buildings were swung around to form one huge circus.
His invention would open up a whole new world in the realm of public entertainment.
Morning, story, pay seven dollars.
You're first to make it.
Yeah, listen, what do you think of that?
Open up!
The buildings in the older section of the city were fire hazards.
Local firemen had their hands full.
The gift of eloquence, much like fire, needs to be fueled.
And like fire, it must depend on motion for existence and sheds light only by burning itself out.
Now, if it ever happens at fire...
Good day, good day. For the glory of Rome, we are going to build roads.
So simple, really. Look, some sand, a few pebbles, some flagstones.
They'll begin right here.
Now for a little demonstration. Watch me well. First a slab.
Well, no, that's not it. First the sand, then your slab. Some pebbles.
No, no, not the pebbles. The slab. I mean a pebble.
The roads will lead from this column. From this hub they'll run like spokes over the world.
Such glory for Rome. Of course for me.
But Great Caesar's going down!
The rules of the Roman road will proceed straight ahead, regardless of terrain.
Which, uh, could sometimes cause problems.
Construct a superb amphitheater.
But, Master, I've no plans for that, none at all.
We've no materials to use, all the flagstones are in the road.
Baa! Right away!
Go on, go on!
Now, listen here now, I wouldn't get inconvenienced or too much, tell me where's the road.
Uh, but, General, have you seen the magnificent amphitheater? We've built in its place.
Huh?
Do you agree?
Order of Caesar, you're to keep building!
Artists and soldiers will never agree.
So nice!
That feels good!
Nicer like that.
Wasn't it a good idea to build these hot baths, General?
It's all right, no need for discussion.
You ever tried again?
Just taste a bit of this water, it's excellent.
You've been ordered to Rome, Master Caesar's orders.
This chariot has been assigned to you.
Oh, no, no, none of these hot rods for me.
My litter.
These are a little puny.
I'll take, uh, that and that one.
Seating with my urban renewal plan will demolish the walls of the old city.
And rewrote the timer.
Rearrange the campus martius.
And construct the Roman Forum right here.
But Caesar, there isn't enough room.
What? Not enough room. It's up to us to make room.
Buildings are torn down, only to be put back together.
Lowers the unemployment rate.
Promises, promises, that's all you'll ever hear, my fellow Romans.
Unite against our oppressors. Strength in numbers.
It's ridiculous what's happening in our city.
It's enough of this tyranny.
With the help of my latest invention, you'll be freed from your tiring chores, you'll see.
Fine, all right, roll em!
Look here now, a brilliant stroke.
Ah, there now.
But what's going on?
Hold it, ah, wait, this isn't happening.
Oh, my stars and goddesses.
Jupiter's quackiness, oh, no, no, no, no, no, no, no!
In spite of one or two minor setbacks, work is proceeding normally.
Not much progress being made here.
All must be finished in eight months.
Caesar, uh, twelve months.
No, eight months.
Listen here now, Caesar.
And listen to Grandad.
Well, I'm listening.
Each year we have first spring, then summer, fall, then winter, followed by another spring, summer, and so forth and so on.
The full moon returns three times each season, in theory anyway, depending on the season.
That makes a total of 365 days, one year, 12 months, see?
I agree, that's the way it is.
And so, 46 years before the year one, our calendar, the Julian, was invented.
Oh, come and look.
After you.
My very latest invention.
A water clock.
A work of genius, don't you think?
Fire! Fire!
Rain!
Don't be rewarded.
These are slaves, you can't just do that.
That's enough.
That's my business.
Settle it with your superiors.
Don't forget my rays.
Lucius Sergius' new house is built atop one of the city's seven hills.
Because of their bravery during the fire, our friends have a pleasant time of it there.
Red house, thanks.
Not bad, and you?
Coming, Pierrette.
Usually shaven, well, practically, Lucius Sergius is ready to receive his clientele.
They tell him their problems, and he dispenses counsel, recommendations, or even better, sportula.
Can be a few silver coins, a basket laden with food, as long as there is food to give.
Lucius, in turn, pays a visit to his patron to reassure him of his undying loyalty.
And they understand each other perfectly.
And how is, my dear friend?
Fine, quite fine, my friend.
That's it?
Go!
Pay for this!
Ha ha ha ha!
Ha ha ha ha ha ha!
Watch out!
What?
Human citizens spent a great deal of their time engaged in political discussion, and sometimes, in the most unlikely places.
See your future in the stars!
And this healthy young man! Let me read your part!
Who wants to buy my fine young man fresh off the ship from Nubia?
Hmm?
And how about this fair young lady?
Eh, my good friends, come see!
None other than my very latest invention, my column-driving machine!
It's absolute perfection, just brilliant, eh what? Here comes he!
Stop him! Mess! Stop it! Shut it up! Oh lordy, out of bed!
Evening falls. Dark streets are no longer safe.
The citizens of Rome return home, bar their doors, and make sure all valuables are safely inside.
After that, the only sounds echoing through the streets are the rumble of convoys laden with food and supplies for the city.
We're late, Pyrrha.
Hello.
Hard now.
We bust one length.
There's a ball suspended in the sky, which forms a solid hollow sphere around it.
Inside the sphere involves the sun shining on all the poor devils who live upside down on the other side of the earth.
All along the Tiber, where Pyrrha's gone for a stroll, can be found riches from all over the world.
Egyptian wheat, Spanish oil, lead, copper, silver, ivory, fabric, spices, silks.
But Pyrrha's master is waiting for him at the baths.
Good day, Ave, my partner's here.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Stop, a bit higher there.
But you, hello.
But, wait for me.
The constellation of the stars predicts great changes for Rome.
Whatever am I doing here?
Yes, there will be great changes.
Jesus, I appreciate your concern, my friend, but I wouldn't dare.
No.
Decades later, a child was conceived whose birth would mark the year one of our modern era.
That birth would have an unparalleled impact on the history of mankind.